hey everybody Welcome to multiple
players uh International Edition because
as you see I've got a fine array of
gentlemen from all over the world on the
couch with me I'm your host Chris Waters
we're playing Mario Kart 8 some quick
introductions Dan Hines from Australia
hey how you doing I'm Dan I'm good this
is your first time playing Mario Kart 8
it really is and actually your first
since when was your last Mario Kart
Mario Kart 64 yes so you played Mario
Kart 8
then bam bam sorry uh Martin Gaston
hello out of straight out of the UK
Martin how how was your Mario Kart 8
game you feel you're bringing table
played it once uh but I won
so undfeated how hard can it be right
I'm going to accelerate I'm going to
take those Corners real nice yeah and um
see how it goes Daniel DWI just
scrolling through all your at mentions
I'm trying to retweet not even on a
godamn live stream right now have we
started yet we're going to we're going
to choose our characters are we only
allowed Play 50 minutes of this before
Nintendo tell us to stop is that are we
okay now I Nintendo takes a cut from any
profit we make off this when did this
game come out like Saturday night weird
time if any of you guys pick Roy I swear
to God
Larry Larry are we all Koopa Kids y I'm
gonna be roselina actually because she I
don't know any of who the [__]
lwi look lwi is just Sonic the
Hedgehog I'm going to be Sonic I'm going
to be Sonic are you still going to ride
that bear yes because it looks really
weird all right if you're a bear I'm
going to be a caterpillar yeah you know
the bolt of the insect
world I'm going to be this plain thing
get on theuk button
Wheels I feel like lwig is a is a Paras
is that you straight biking it is that
Martin why not rid why not bit of
variety terrible idea all right let's go
to Mario Kart Stadium where all the
people go to watch are we going to do in
the Mario Kart Stadium we're going to
drive our babies around this why are
there so many babies why is everyone a
baby now cute why is there no baby lwig
I think lwig is a baby is he or is he
like a tween it's like a slightly
slightly more effort than a pallet swap
but yeah not really just the age swap
yeah oh God I'm turning oh God this is
on you got the motion controls instantly
handicapped and uh all right you're back
I'm going the right give me all your
coins [__]
D oh you're the worst oh God okay my
favorite feature of the split screen is
the low frame R yeah how do I so
apparently half the screen is being
refreshed any time so it's straight up
is 60 and like one or two player yeah
msh was telling us that right so it's
it's alternating the frame every other W
I fell off so that so like the HUD which
appears all the time is in 60 frames but
the how do you use
cor your parasol it's it's fine it's
fine you got it I got it it's good are
you fine you're driving how is it going
on
your Robin is racing your what raccoon I
don't know I've got some animals a
parachute raccoon I see one of your
American things raccoon yeah that's an
American animal and it's not poisonous
really because on Australia jokes get it
yeah drop bears super good one drop you
don't get those drop airs there's a
bullet behind me get
away which one you use the bullet cheat
that's a cheat a the motorcycle seem
different they don't seem like the carts
made a bit of a bit of an error in
judgment froming the uh I see why you
were like motorcycle the game do you
remember when that was incredulous about
your motorcycle Choice yes yeah that
when can we change that was telling when
are we allowed to choose three more
races why why do you collect coins coins
coins coin West why why would you not
why would you call good point uh your
top speed will increase slightly with
the amount of coins you have up to 10
coins really yes
awesome so ruffle those coins you got
just gobble them up
I got the star screw you
guys I just drove off the edge of the
map oh I just got name I don't think
lwig has a driver's license he really
it's don't even his can't no he stole it
off an estate and he's just driving it
around but he's the prince of uh of um
you got a bullet use the bullet Southern
Germany so bull immediately at all times
holding eight baby I just want to point
out that I couldn't figure out why I was
slowing down it's cuz I let go of
accelerate these aren't the ones that
this this caterpillar doesn't drive
itself you got to do something fun isn't
it it's good Marin yeah it's good yeah
no it's a good time I literally came
last yeah you did literally you got one
point though so oh good the token that's
more than no one else you finished
behind Toadette when was the last good
Mario character that they introduced and
don't say lwig character are you talking
about yeah like new character Metal
Mario right that's not Char oh right
that's a baby P so yeah you're going to
have to choose next race the default is
to do that's Anno we're not going to do
that Waluigi Martin got it Waluigi
Waluigi what the last new character last
good new character good new because
Waluigi is a good character look at us
we're on we're in weird picture and
picture Danny has discovered the monitor
where he can look at the live stream
while he's on the live stream it's great
because you guys are like floating in
midair yeah we're we're up here on a
whole different level this is like a
double decker couch
yeah I think Waluigi is the
best
new who the hell is Rosalina she's the
one from Mario Galaxy who's like the
queen of the cosmos or something yes she
is didn't she's queen of all Cosmos you
think that the prince Was A Bachelor oh
my God hell no guys I'm underw even the
Katamari games have better new
characters than Mario
Kart write it
up up gam spot says
I camari's new character such as who
Danny prin king of allos tiny ass Prince
yeah the king of all Cosmos is the Mario
of the kadari universe so you can't this
is getting meta
yeah oh gosh oh gosh oh de oh that's a
wall I hit something in mid a it's the
Mario
wheel oh you're singing the Mario song
Mario the one where he just keeps
singing his name Mario
It's a
Mario we can't sing the actual one
because we' have to pay Nintendo so it's
like the happy birthday yeah Mario Kart
we need to we need to Overlay the
graphics with just like handdrawn
characters I thought you going to say
with like lyrics subtitles yeah everyone
knows the Mario lyrics
already everyone's aware of Welcome to
Mario Kart I hope you will enjoy the
show Mario Kart mar Mario Mario
Mario who says marioart Mario Mario yeah
Mario Mario I love how it's Posh when I
say Mario but not when you say
Mario look isn't that your thing let's
get
Mario it's the name of I don't know why
that hasn't been it will you Mario me no
I'm Wasing my oh no I stuck
on yes oh no I've changed my mind oh
you that is difficult to respons my
coins fell
out yeah that'll happen H well I mean
you are playing as Sonic right or yeah
I'm I'm Sonic get away it's Sonic rules
basically I'm I'm chocolate Peach Sonic
rules chocolate Peach well she looks
like she's like wrapped in foil or
something you know like chocolate yeah I
know she's totally uh what oh I'm stuck
in the ball what chocolate is wrapped in
foil no foil chocolate comes wrapped in
foil no it doesn't what what do you mean
in Australia I don't understand in oh
yeah Kit Kat comes out in yeah but
that's that's it what what does
chocolate come in this definitely wer or
something like a plastic wrapper or a
foil wrapper like just plastic what if
you're buying a fancy slab of chocolate
it's like a big rectangle of nice
chocolate no like like cabur dairy milk
or something plastic listen Cadbury's
makes cream eggs and that's all I know
of yeah that's in foil as
well all Easter eggs oh the point is I'm
right yeah he's pretty right
what Mega right they don't even have
chocolate in Australia
whatever it's actually
much it's actually drop
bears they rat and foil where is the
drop bears thing even from everyone
always says Australia yes it's from it's
from my country you got to be real
careful it's not a is it a real thing
what the hell is going on I just blasted
you with a green shell when you're in
the cannon drop is
like most Australians don't die of
natural es they die from drop ATT drop
bears are naturally occurring we di have
awesome causes isn't that a natural
cause well good point I mean if it was
like a meca drop bear then that are you
telling me that like being eaten by a
shark is a dying of natural causes
telling me does that logic not apply
being murdered in your sleep oh it's
just you know yeah like a tree falls on
you and stoves your head in natural CA
if you're knocked down by a car it's not
natural but if you're knock down down by
like a boulder
sure the cars are made of metal which is
found in that is true drived from nature
is there any true artificial cause for
death
ghosts ghosts exist only in our minds
yeah they're not real ghosts and ghost
and E numbers and playing too much
Starcraft negative square roots South
Korean internet cafe style that's not
natural that's the reason that dud was
news it was the first unnatural death in
ever
yeah oh God it just appears to be some
sort of confectionary course much like
while playing sonic I can't keep this
[__] on the actual
map I just drove through a donut and
straight into a wall there oh God was it
good for the donut you know you'd have
to ask the donut they were out of the
door Mario powers Mario
Kart that's how it goes that's the words
this version of Mario Kart has
headlights when you go in the tunnel
yeah it's good it could have just lit
the
tunnel saved a lot headlights
for for for allowing other people in
their Mario Karts to go before you at
Crossroads is this map the sweet candy
one yeah sweet candy mountain or yeah
Candy Land or something I think it's a
wreck Ralph situation would Mario Kart
be more fun if you had to use blinkers
what indicators yeah there you go Jesus
blinkers blink are you if you like
waggle to
turn you get a little speed boo that's
how you get the speed boost is waggling
to turn your properly into this we need
to like work in learning proper driving
you know we are all real bad at Mario
Kart I came in first what are you
talking about I'm still going I was just
going I finished so I mean he's he's
getting more play time I have come last
every single time consistent I was so I
was so mystified by the fact that I was
playing Z Sonic third race so you would
have had one point every time happened
to must come second probably beat an AI
something when did Nintendo buy the
rights to Zuul yeah what we just played
it like candy the choa chops land wasn't
that was the one we the an you had to
push down like qua crack oh push over
push something Colin Quaver's quer James
Pon 2 was sponsored by penguin and
chocolate bars oh God you remember that
we got a bit Regional now he's just a
bit too Regional deep Regional James
Pawn 2 I did I recognize that phrase of
it I was I don't think Z made it over
here I see I thought you were talking
about like a Ghostbusters reference
talking about Z zul was this like weird
ninja it's not ninja ant yeah he's like
the Amiga it was a commodor nin joint it
was like he was our Sonic basically yeah
bring back zul wasn't Sonic your
Sonic no Sonic the Japan no but I mean
oh all right so you're talking about not
like the experience of your youth but
like oh no no one played Z I think Jazz
Jack Rabbit was out Sonic Jazz jack
rabbit in Europe they called Sonic
ludvig they did yeah uh they did they
changed it in later years because of
globalization in the original yeah was
Dr Eggman yeah and ludvig L viig the
Hedgehog didn't roll off the have you
seen that video of the brainstorming me
where they're coming up with Sonic no
it's the F show It's the funniest thing
some some UK
film hey did you see that thing no okay
all right great we'll watch it later
yeah you know what's going to be good is
watching that at another time you know
he just not watch this live stream and
go watch that instead it's funny I mean
let me tell you about a whole bunch of
funny things you could watch on the
internet that you know are different
than what this is he so if you have two
invincible people and they bump into
each other what happens uh they bounce
off each other
exp everything dies had an Unstoppable
Force an immovable object a star youit
bullet
sorry
Mario it's me Baby Mario he's not in
this one in Italy Mario is actually
called Dave
Dave and his brother Craig he's a window
Craig that Italian that old Italian name
smooth day oh no he's actually he's
actually from Hackney in the Italian
version he's taxi yeah he's he's cabie
he's got views on immigration I'll tell
you
that you
Scottish is this still Mario in other
countries we're talking about or have
you moved on to the rich
fiction just a different name in history
because there was like a trademark or
something is it actually called
something else I can't
even yes lost we lost it lost the thre
allor right not sure what is real and
what is
true if I press the Z button ludvig like
just freaks out for some reason I don't
know why he's doing
it maybe it's cuz he realizes he's a
[__]
character it's so it's an of
Crisis oh [__] I'm a terrible character
what am I even doing oh my God I nothing
to this game I'm useless I'm just a crap
Sonic a German name I'm not even Waluigi
levels
rubbish God toad Dash oh that was it
that's Mario Kart that's it wrap it up
see you in eight years good episode see
you next year mamoto looking forward to
Mario Kart 9 announced that this year's
E3 you can play as each of the Wii music
instruments we are reaching like Olympic
levels of myio Kart apathy right now
it's really good it's we're all having a
very fun I'm having a lovely look got
it's got Mortal Kombat TV Great combat
TV
Babality yeah some somebody hit Babality
button a couple more a couple too much
when they're making this game can we
upload this to YouTube now can we sit to
YouTube and wait for half an hour yeah
sweet it actually works surprisingly
well for a Nintendo product Oh this is
chronicl my I was going to say like what
does that even mean that track came
first these were my finished
CU I think I won the cup cuz I'm the
greatest you think he won the cup and
America rules guess I think I won the
cup oh is this a national thing yeah
should we all pick the character that
most embodies the nation we come from
yes absolutely I think Waluigi is the
big get out here Dan H good luck with
that character selection here we go yeah
Green oh careful we have to make sure we
do it the right
order 150 all right number one I'm going
join when do I press the button now
now all right good
who is the most American of all of these
people there's literally a character
called Larry yeah Jesus Jesus
Nintendo Roy here's Roy Roy everyone's
favorite pretty cool to be fair baby
Rosalina are we picking our national
identity here yeah I feel like Wario is
not a bad B I think [__] most looks
like he would kill me so let's go with
him who went with donkey you think the
UK is Donkey Kong no I was going on the
thing of the games were good ones but
they're a bit crap now which to
represent the UK I guess yashi is the
Easy Choice cuz he's a massive alcoholic
so I don't know I feel like Mario has
the more better signs of you know yeah
that's true actually years of hard
drinking got that big red nose I feel
like uh what obesity yeah yeah also that
yeah he just real immoderate behaviors
these are very English also just like
Bowser greed on his face plainly RIT cuz
he's evil yeah CU he steals the pink
what fine Peach are you Peach yeah I
like calling her pink instead cuz that's
what she was call okay well I'm
literally riding on a bear now so that's
perfect oh yeah you're definitely all
set I'm going to get in a c what's the
most Irish form of trans most
ostentatious of all of these cars
where's the SUV's that thing the SUV
land ship yeah this one's a boat on land
that's very Victorian that peachy paraso
is very Victorian
yep that's like a tea party I'm going to
have a flower a motorcycle a motorcycle
jet sure I don't know what I have it's
some sort of chopping trolley his butt
is barely fitting on that yeah yeah I
feel I mean should it be busting out all
over look look at him make that pop out
Baby Got Back
bam good gracious we're just going to do
that for the rest of the stream you guys
going to watch I wow I think Rio is a
power bottom
po what are you try what are you even
trying to say nothing
nothing that one's Bowser one is a plane
I'm going to choose the plane Americans
invented planes right yeah yeah
absolutely right right Brothers right
which one should we do and just let's
just do the next we had a hard enough
time with bloody that's true yeah St
Grand Prix we're going to go with the
new tracks but there are a lot of retro
tracks also in this of course uh do you
guys have any like favorite
you called the rainbow road is a road
that
you when you die yeah rest in peace
Uncle
hey that's another good video on the
which Buton makes them stop singing the
the center horn button actually yep you
need to press I don't know how to do the
jump anymore I Used to Know bam there it
is anyone I'm just going to make a
practice of trying to drive in front of
all you
B looks like just so you can see Mario's
huge ass huge ass I have a flower that's
eating things on my that's not cool yeah
that's a new power up cool they pety
piranha as a usable character yeah and
just they itemized him because he had no
legs uh yeah it might have been a a
legist move uh moved by the leg Lobby to
squash all role models that have no legs
those guys need to get it yeah they they
can't though cuz they're the leg Lobby
they're the hand Lobby they don't have a
those guys can stand on son of a that
was
better oh no oh God these dudes on top
of each other pass
nice oh I just hit the this is to Tokyo
dri oh I just directly off the track di
oh you son of a e it what a yeah you
overt me time this just such it is fun I
don't even know why I'm doing it it's a
good game it's really enjoyable God I'm
a douche I'm so sorry so cynical it's
really good I hate myself I I don't know
why am this
way I am getting such Joy from this game
it is a really good game for some re I'm
just being a complete [__] about it's
cuz you've played it before no I
probably cuz you're so comfortable with
it you know you can rib it it's like you
guys can J around and make fun of each
other but no one's feelings get hurt at
the end like a sibling Mario Kart's like
a
sibling yeah I think this is this is a
good analogy never
changes never changes it's a constant
sort of disappointment and it always
wants money and yet you love it so you
abide it you I'm sorry I love my family
tolerated really awful really I hope
your brothers aren't watching thisal
not been like getting along
lately here's a good tip if you ever
don't know someone's family member game
just make up an alliterative one yeah
what the hell's going on with my super
car eat a shell get hit by that shell AI
maybe oh you absolute son of a gypsy I'm
just going to assume you're talking
about shell you can't say stuff like
that and not making raci
SLS call me a Jippo I would never ever
do that I came second that's nice I was
I was third until everyone overtook me
at the end because Mario Kart cuz Mario
Mario Kart happened got drilled by a
shell did I come last again not quite oh
nice progress you are were you oh you
were playing as everyone's favorite
Mario Kart character Morton Morton yeah
have a range of fine
steakhouses true Morton is actually a
successful entrepreneur is he just looks
like a bit of a wild child doesn't he
have the antivirus software that we used
to have yeah Morton Morton's always
turning up on my machine yeah the Koopa
kids are real into virus software
protection I got Morton free with my
windows based are you kidding me didn't
he want star in the Hulk I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure Ludwig is responsible
for the heart boo security yeah oh
that's a wall that's a wall my favorite
[__] movie is American History X
American hisory was fantastic he was
really good in that movie can I burst
through this box not very
speedily hey
hey uh I know I liked him in the I liked
Morton as the Hulk but then it turns out
I like Mark Ruffalo better Mark Ruffalo
is a better Morton than Ed
[__] but he was really good in the Sha
Shang Redemption as well he's just he's
talented such you know what I've always
wanted to be in a Mario Andy do Frain is
like you've always wanted to be in a mar
no more
SP to a water on the telephone you're
right listen hey yeah oh I got cheats do
you want some antivirus go down this all
way I do not have the maneuverability to
handle that kind of thing so why isn't
Morton in Smash
Brothers he do V
yeah he's Buddhist he's
pretty he looks like a bit of a bully
that's why he hates V so much cuz he's
he's one of those expectations people
are always thinking yeah he's I'm a nice
guy Jesus
Christ I I got a big horn did you just
fcking super horn me I did you been
waiting on the horn one for that 20
minutes that's the first time I've seen
the horn and I've played this game quite
a lot and did you use it to just destroy
an item intended no I just used it oh I
got the one that's item barf yeah I got
that that's the best the horn is
[__] right the Horn's like what I
think I just item bared myself the horn
is Nintendo added in this new weapon
realized it was [__] and then never has
it so it never comes
up you never get the horn no one gets
the horn no one gets the horn no one
gets the horn in in the Nintendo well
like we fixed the blue shell just take
out the blue shell we fixed the blue
shell but adding in an item you will
never ever get ever I don't think I've
gotten it a single time in all of my how
do you balance
you son of a [__] e it you son of a
[__] let me win this one no let me win
yeah it's too late oh [__] almost hit
that thing see I you know what I'd
really like now you're getting excited
now oh get jumped oh I'm getting
in my plant ate the
ink I like that I'm too far behind son
of a [__] get some more
speed go go go take out that b did get
some more speed
is that tram are we in San Francisco we
are in San Francisco yeah this is oh you
son of a [__]
no Mario
Kart
Mar did you wait until the last second
to do that I didn't even come up on my
screen I had I had a banana I didn't hit
him at all someone else did was it you
no but I won you son of a [__] I I
didn't fire the weapon I was first that
whole l i was opportunistic you son of a
[__] wa didn't even come up it didn't
even come up stop doing your Mario Kart
andess W up to marioart oh God that's
horrifying it's just different enough
from the real Mario that's what Sonic's
voice actually but we don't have to pay
theend any money it's true yeah
it's yeah it's me Mario Mario now pay
Nintendo anything it is me I am Mario
but if you do it's a me Mario pay him
like $5 reg's on the blower oh I forgot
to go [__] sake that's literally the
only thing you have to do at the start
of the race yeah Y is begin racing go
forward my engine exploded whoa we're on
the walles we're in someone's house yeah
yeah this is not trespassing this house
has a lot of ghosts in Mario Kart is
down with trespassing for sure Mario
Kart loves
trespasses oh my God it's the water room
yeah you little bastard stare to the
water room I'm having that
fumigated for some
reason
terrible understanding of how we get
water in thisel gases various states of
matter oh man oh gosh oh you son of a
Bach look I'm going out for the night
and I don't mind if you kids you know
driving little cars around but you just
you just stay out of the water room okay
I'm just I just I I really insist none
of you drive in the water room I'm okay
all of the coings Just pee in the water
room anyways when they go there now
we're having the ghosts around as well
so try and give them a bit of you know
wide bit room you know they don't like
being looked
at my brain
hurts oh oh you son of I just blew
myself with the
bomb up blew myself up going to have to
get rid of the seaw I'll leave when I'm
good and
ready never rested an El another good
thing you could be watching on the
internet right
now moment Netflix has got some quality
program Netflix does have some have you
seen Orange is the New Black Orange Is
the New I haven't seen that yet oh
that's really good it's very good is
this what other Netflix program great
drama I enjoyed House of Cards House of
Cards is very good had a question that I
did I I was so Dam
understanding just coming up at the the
end of your sentence yeah I mean I'm
doing the inflection Dan is focusing
very hard on being in 10th place right
now it's it's not easy being 10th you're
so good at it in fact you have to be
very specifically you don't have to
certain level of
skill I can't drive where am I
going stop but I want to
go I'm so
conflicted I I'm going to be honest I
haven't been paying as much attention to
this this particular particular race
after winning the last one I thought you
know what I'll give the chaps a bit of I
came for it is that why I'm still last
oh I hit the you're almost not last we
you are not last sorry guys you'll have
to wait for me oh that's a
wall who steer steer God that's a trick
wait wait wait wait wait rocking it off
into the Wilderness remember when we
finished this race 10 minutes ago to go
directly into the tree when we were
space so many elements the arrows the
the pace of the turn of the track they
want you to go right who the [__] is
pressure yeah oh are you kidding me
everyone he's the one that throws the
Hammers he was the guy in Mario 64 that
had the camera and you had to I didn't
know he had a name you don't know who
litu is no I just called him the dude in
the cloud just call him l
he's he's the man in the sky it's shy
guy falls it's shy guy falls the flower
cup I this is where shy guys working
grueling Minds support the shy guy this
is why they're shy yeah you like having
iph these shy guys dig out iPhones from
these mountainous areas for three p an
hour I gu this is this this is a real
parable of globalization are you saying
that the shy guys are the migrant
laborers of the Mario World yeah and
that's why when you fall off and trying
to kill yourself you just come back you
can't do it that's cuz they've got the
Nets suicide nets all right no that's
why there's the guy always picking you
up off the track yeah's job you get back
making those iPhones oh that guy oh so
it's that guy yeah it's the guy who like
the the one lap left final lap dud Mario
Kart is yeah he's he's a he's the Jack
of all trades he just needs the money
he's got lots of kids it does LY liy
Larry more
a that guy
with pink Beach from from that summer he
spent in Austria dude just keep it in
your pants right you got enough kids as
it
is there's only so many shifts you can
do at the holding the camera
job oh I just [__] I'm worse at this
game if you could make your own new
charact Mario character CU let's be
honest we've been pretty down on this
let's come up with some positive
I feel like we need some more dinosaurs
dinos you know Yoshi is a great dinosaur
uh well Koop is kind of a dinosaur wait
a minute evil Yoshi with like a big old
mustache yeah I think Yoshi needs some
sort of why
Yosi why why why Yi he's got a big old
mustache he's real
cranky um he's vaguely Italian he has a
human tongue which is really unnerving
he just like WS out of his
mouth
Mario Kart Mario Kart Nintendo Mario
Kart it's good like is there any
characters in this game like how about a
giant spider yes and it's super
realistic looking like it scares the
crap out of
kids any sense yeah he's part of the new
horror Zone yeah people say they didn't
want us to be so family friendly anymore
so we made this realistic
spider it'll haunt your you wish for
Yoshi now don't you your little your
little SP we already and that was a
Nintendo E3 conference
2014 I'd like Marcus Phoenix to be in
this
game
retweeting what uh so the Locust in
Gears of War say retreating sometimes
just retweeting but it's really easy to
hear it as a retweeting and then never
hear it as anything else
again so when Gears of War six is up you
know again this year uh
spoilers who's Yoshi obviously Yoshi I
was Yoshi pass you at the end I don't
care wait wait wait damn it Danny you're
apathy first or I don't care that's what
it is I got double first double
first that's what they cool you are neck
and neck with Baby Luigi a baby Compu I
lost a few spots on that one all right
we got one more was that it that was it
that was it why can't you drive his
Bullet Bill's the next one Bullet Bill
should be in the game all right Bullet
Bob could be in we're going to do a
thing here bullet Craig uh guys we need
to take a quick break bullet Craig we're
good all right we're GNA go to battle
mode though what because cuz it's crap
in this
game yeah no one told me there was going
to be any battle mode all right I'm not
prepared for this no you are because
battle mode is basically just racing
around the track aimlessly withouts good
yeah we're going to do one of those how
what we were just doing some of us were
trying to go in a certain direction for
most of the time uh all the time they
spend putting Liu into the game they
could have spent making a better battle
mode L
like
fin does that like lady I don't know I
don't even know if you're being
offensive but just on the case that you
are what's going on that's bad you're
being cover your bases if you're not I'm
sorry s like a battle City in Nigeria
all right uh no freaking no you have to
go next you have to go next you guys did
it wrong sorry come on sorry B think of
the oh my God back all the way out to
multiplayer maybe who did that pink old
Peach all right yeah look at that look
at all those babies there's so many
babies all right this is going to be a
baby battle who's looking after all
these babies everyone's got to choose a
baby next are we doing baby mode yeah
where is there no baby
latiu you know if you're a babysitter
don't let him get in a goddamn cart does
lemy count as a baby no he no say baby
hey hey he was small he's pretty small
I'm going to choose the most [__] of
all the babies baby Daisy I don't know I
think baby Rosalina could lay claims to
that yeah fair enough just saying you
got a kid all the babies you got a
three-year-old kid imagine you have a
child yes and you going out Chris you're
going to have to watch a film or
something in the cinema you've had a
nice like Super Duper Burger you and
then you realize that your babysitter
has strapped your baby into a goddamn
cart and set it loose in a ghost house
made of candy or something where you're
not supposed to go into the water
room why would you let that happen I
feel like I would not give that
babysitter EG and I let you drink all
the booze in the fridge no no te you
this to me why did you drive RZ normal
let's make the Comm easy cuz you guys
are all terrible hey hey we got biger to
fly who let these babies courses choose
yeah sure put the Communists on
hard it's moooo
Meadows mum meows Mo Meadows here we
goow how about a how about a cow
character what kind of what what would
be the personality of a cow character in
Mario Kart they love grass yep seven
stomachs or something right a a little
too literal in terms of their Anatomy
here they have
ERS yeah would they would they have
black and white spots they would Co if
they bump into another cow on the C
they'd both go
insane and start just frothing and
attacking everyone like a rage mode okay
would they would the white Parts turn
red in Rage mode yes all right now we're
talking all right I'm just going to sit
here and blast wait why are you going
the other way doesn't matter oh man I
hope I get another green shell yeah you
can just go around wherever the hell you
want you could hide behind a cow and
leap out at an opportunity so I'm
allowed done that to actually run off
the track this time it right
now so all this is is they take out the
they took out the laps and made it so
that you only ever pick up green shells
that's silly [__] wait B mode is
universally recognized as [__] there are
also bananas just I'm just going to hide
by this cow look at this cow it's so
it's tots of dorbs look at this guy I
mean is anyone watching this does anyone
ever go like oh yeah I can't Mar Kart
can't wait down to battle mode that
stuff is
great oh man that over a basically I'm
saying I love marioart but ble mode
sucks yeah I just hit a cow I feel bad
now
ow the
to the other bab can I play as like a
camper like in Battlefield and just sort
of sit and wait with a show Dan and I
are going to go in a reverse race yeah
this game is almost stable than that
reverse or gt I don't see any
loling Evolution all right I'm dead I
killed you did you sweet release hey so
you can still play you're invisible yeah
I can still play I'm invisible I can
still pick up items you perish mess with
people yeah I murdered him I got my baby
to kill his baby baby Crystal Waters
died 2014 inum Meadow M Mead yeah his
parents are very sad we have this level
it's got lots of grass and cows what
should we call it Mr baby
tombstone oh God Moto come in come into
the office we need your help what is it
what is it we need you to name this
course okay hyp what's it got it's got C
it's got cows it's got windmill it's got
a dead baby gravestone all right leave
with me boys I'm going home we're
thinking we're thinking we're going to
call it
carfield CFI calfi is good but we're
Nintendo we can do better than that the
P the pasture
Zone we Sonic God damn get out of my
office get out of my office call it
other other field I like it I like how
of fi let's put that on put that on the
board 7 hours later sorry Mr Mr mimo
what you talking about we what we we can
have we going to call it moo Meadows moo
Meadows you're a goddamn idiot we need
to Moo like C just says move one time
gives up yeah that's quitter talk you're
out you're never going to work in this
city again boy move medows you
freak now Mo Moon Meadows now that's got
sign now we're talking now we're talk
God I'm good God I'm good God I'm good
give me a water on the phone yeah
where's we music too a I made that game
it's
brilliant I was there that's exactly how
it happened to be a fly on the wall I
was a fly on the wall and that mean
that's how it happened did I win that I
can't tell there's three rounds you get
points for uh knocking a balloon off
someone so you're probably still in
first okay Dr dry dry desert whoever
[__] named Mumu meows C back in yeah
I think donut donut Plains we'll call it
rainbow Rainbow Road rainbow Rainbow
Road come on Bo it's too many he's gone
too far why it's me Moto my control my
control V is stuck I just got a copy of
the game it's real good I I see you took
my suggestions on MooMoo Meadows and dry
Dr desert what the godamn hell were you
thinking when you didn't call it rainbow
rainbow road I quit one rainbow who
wants to see that you're you're a godamn
descri let me show you this internet
video it says double Rainbow on it
people are going bonkers you're God that
rainbow rainbow road are you kidding me
you're breaking my
balls yeah he's like that yeah he just
puts that nice guy thing on camera I
know it's really weird and does a great
job you hit record you hit record he
just yeah he stops being a Italian
American it's really weird the second
you hit record it when it
come there's some babies I can
murder Jesus Christ
Christopher listen it's battle mode I'm
battling babies what's the goal of all
battle murder Lamentations of their
babies and such you know it' be great if
this instead of being a racing circuit
was just some sort of area in which we
can actually hunt to shut her down
instead of being compelled to drive
forward for absolutely no reason
whatever I like Mario Kart if any
there's some kind of battle mode that's
what it's missing get back here baby
lugie
lugie yeah baby lugie that's an insult
version of your real name cuz that was
come here that's a dry dry all this is
probably a stupid question but what does
the boomerang do oh it does that wow wow
wow that was well
played when he said oh it does that that
was him throwing it directly into my
face that's just for you guys the
Highlight he's
Australian and he yet
he this is your Nations if there was
some sort of national International War
where everyone was only allowed to use
one weapon that was culturally
significant australi Army be throwing
boomerangs cuz America would get guns
yeah you guys would get
guns England would get cannons like
ocean cannons one those really sh guns
that have to be reloaded every time you
fire them those things arand would have
Stones Stones maybe a hurly early yeah
is a hurly like a real mean hit and
stick stick yeah it is the hid and stick
isn't it and then you get the tiny ball
we don't call it the we call that
slitter but oh whoa hid and stick and
Tiny ball work oh that was in your face
you can get my head Dan now that you
live in America do you still watch hle
ball I do I watched the game last week
it was on 8 in the morning my social
life is ruined my baby self the mon
remember I used to remember I used to
get off and i' watch the grand PRI when
we live together I have to do that now
5: in the morning it's the absolute
worst yeah man sport is ruining my life
there are things to be fan of that
happen at normal people hours that is
true yeah but not F1 there was a WWE
event yesterday in the daytime which is
amazing cuz it's usually have to stay
off why the [__] okay this has happened
to me twice why is it the boxes they're
disappearing on oh it's because there's
some ghost going around stealing them
there we couldn't figured it out you
can't get insurance what type of battle
mode
finishes before it the death of everyone
except
one which one am I Lugia Jesus Christ Mr
mamoto these battles are going on too
long it's half an hour and they can't
find each other just make it end
prematurely they you crazy we got much
bigger problems than have the battles of
fun or not have you seen the name of
that Toad Harbor toad toad Harbor right
Bo come on what do you mean are we going
all retro here well see now he's just
like put a number in he can't be
bothered saying that Toad Harbor I
believe was in Sonic Adventure
yeah what was looks like the levels from
Sonic and then the whale came up yeah
and Sonic was running into the screen
and that was
incredible there are kids who there are
kids who weren't there who who like if
you were like oh that whale bit in Sonic
Adventure they'd be like what
whale yeah are you saying there's people
that don't know about stuff in the world
yeah loads of them are in like like
Russia and Africa yeah and some some are
dead and some are there's lots of people
who don't know some some are dead a list
of people that don't know about Sonic
Adventure right now we got to find them
I got a new Mission you got to tell them
the good word about the Chow Walkers so
so there was this bit right where this
whale it comes up into the screen and
then it be like
wow like I'm so glad I bought this
Dreamcast I want to buy a Dreamcast
let's go buy Dreamcast I'm going to go
I'm going to go to the toilet and bring
my vmu vmu I'm going to feed that cow KO
and stuff I'm going to play Quake 3 the
way it was meant to be played with a VM
with a with a controller and hacked
servers full of PC
players there we there be people that
don't what I'm under the bridge that's
not good you were like a Red Hot Chili
Pepper song can you get a Red Hot Chili
Pepper Marica uh the Anthony keas DLC is
uh not not talking about it yet we're
not talking about it yet it's called Kus
Kus car Kus Kus I just hit myself with a
green shell we tried to get the flea
flee wanted to be involved but the kids
don't like flee the kids want to play
his they want to they want to play his
Kus the kids love Kus I I hate flea now
I think was called flee flea
yeah if Fleet song about being addicted
to heroin and maybe we could get him in
the game but all he does is sit there
with his top off yeah acts crazy like I
hate
him Anthony C is DLC
another stop revealing all of the e324
announcements but see they do the
Nintendo directs early so we get like
100 embos about do you guys want to do
like a pistols at dawn thing let's all
just like line up somewhere pistol
pistols pistols at now can we all find
it where we are because this let's go to
the finish line or the start line I got
the boomerang oh no someone's on my ass
with a
boomerang baby let's me at the moooo
meow we got 48 hey hey everybody go get
into a clump together everyone get into
the the water get into a what together
Clump we should probably 40 seconds
let's meet at the bridge the one that's
actually all right I'm by the I'm by the
St the bridge let meet the Dan hind
Bridge yeah
hey it's actually Pete's Bridge Pete's
Bridge you go up to it it says we're not
talking about that right now yeah and
then
uh you just went past the bridge come
back sorry sorry P I love you this isn't
going to work we got 15
seconds get to the start like we're not
talking about Fallout let me talk to
let's talk about killer is dead or
something not killer is dead you guys
not doing it what's that game nobody SCS
online yeah let's talk about ESO have to
go
t yay man I had a bomb I was going to
bomb everybody with I am I am just
killing all of you [__] look at
this 19 look at that did you choose baby
roselina is that you for real
can we get this Danny
verified as Ros twin Galaxy going all
right twin Galaxy and we get that dude
with the the so that's battle mode Chris
I love being on your show with battle
mode
sucks ter let's go do some Grand Pricks
Grand pricks I know a grand Pricks got a
whole Couch full of them right here yeah
uh we're going to special let's what
what's this one do no do not don't be
that guy I think that's just look how
into it Mario is wait
if any of you [__] pick baby
roselina before I get a chance swear to
God oh what are you going to do I didn't
want to be it h I'm going to be the me
I'm going to be Tom McShay oh oh you
could be a number of Mees oh my God I
could I could be this guy Gamespot 02
Caro's in here Kevin Bor that does not
look like k b
whatsoever uh player is that Roy has any
anyone been Roy Roy think someone's been
Roy I'm going to be Tom
McShay Tom McShay takes Nam we Kevin
we've got Tom McShay all right I
got I'm Kevin I'm G to kick your ass
with Tom M I'm G to be myself no way
robot cop that's
met I'm going to be
gso2 he's my favorite game definitely a
human being quality his review of Madden
last year was sick M remember he wrote
that paragraph about that cultural issue
and everyone went mental in the comments
it was so on point that dude is in tune
with the Zeitgeist for
reals I like to I want to just tell you
I'm getting pins and needles in my left
hand that's how how exed exting Mario
Kart
is I'm going to be oh look at this kite
it's got waluigi's face on it yes
beautiful orio beauti special that one
one
more bone dry D rainbow rainbow rainbow
we're we're gonna conclude with rainbow
rainbow road so that that dry dry desert
is not dry enough boom
dry one was called bone dry desert bone
dry desert can we have bone dry bone dry
Desert god damn
it what is this
Twitter God damn ruined it again I think
the best character they brought in Mario
monster truck you're wearing is
Tom I forgot I wasn't ble mode yeah what
the [__] are you driving some sort of
rainbow car you are in a comical what is
your car monster from what is that what
a delightful adventure oh look I got the
green shell again it's like battle mode
all over again get away from me brings
back those battle mode
moments ah memories that was a great
game of battle mode said nobody said
nobody how much battling we did battles
there were enough about the new
characters and courses tell me more
about battle mode said the public
eagerly what I'm talking about B mode
when your game only has one other mode
it shouldn't be this it shouldn't be as
bad as it is when you've got one other
mode Mar 9 have battle mode ask the
interviewer e interview e if you were an
interview interviewing Mr Mr Moto about
about Mario Kart what questions would
you ask what are the new additions to
batt mode this year okay this is this is
me this is your video game journalist
license so from my license what
platforms is it going on what
platform will it run what's the frame
rate uh yeah what's the
resolution will it have DLC mhm um
what's the future of mobile games yeah
would you ever make it like a paid
mobile app or something DLC
anthy DLC real or rumor
yeah how many players can you play yeah
is local multiplayer supported oh no all
great question the hell was that is it
free to play yeah is it free to play is
Nintendo like a yeah is it pay to win
what's the Esports plan yeah is it going
to be an
esport is it going to have streaming or
something people have streaming these
days don't they people can't get up
streaming will we see it com to PC come
PC all good questions this is like an
incredible handbook on how to be super
on point how many retail SKS will there
be yeah what are the minimum
requirements what graphics cards should
I have
yeah can I have a free game with it what
what G what Games inspired you guys in
the creation of
Mario mostly Mario Kart how is
this well we're just trying to make the
best game we can right now we don't
really look like outwardly Le for
inspiration we just you know we think
about the team what we want to make and
I mean really it's all it's all about
what players want of course and we take
their feedback Welcome to our new show
apathetic game journalist super cynical
game
journals get the hell out of my face shy
gu go back to the mines wow yeah back to
the salt mines get some iPhones I need
more iPhones that it salty bet would be
a great character for this game just the
muin it just randomly changes every I'm
not last I'm sorry third last what does
it mean when I'm constantly jumping up
and down pumping my fist in the air and
it says a one next to my name means I
think it means you you've got you got to
get the special cream from the pharmacy
got to rub that in somewhere real bad
cannot sitting down or standing up are
equal Agony and I just oscillate between
the two it's horrifying yeah that is my
life now you got crabs I wasn't even
driving this car that's what it is I
need to take a dump get me get me out of
this crazy machine okay when how do we
do the Boost he just press it randomly
now now do it son that didn't work at
all I don't know think I'm going to give
you good information on the last race of
the stream oh [__] you
Sonic if anyone sees Sonic will they hit
him for me yes thank you H the stupid
Stu is that like a does that request
timeout at the end of this race or is
that like in perpetuity going for it's a
keeper yeah just put that on your to-do
list to never check it
on you know that most recent Sonic Mario
Kart was quite good for the record what
Sonic and allar racing Transformers
pretty decent do you remember that year
where they released five of those games
the same week did it have a battle mode
there was remember think there Little
Big Planet caring F1 race Stars Sonic
Allstar Racing and something else all
came out within a week of each other
Yeah Christmas week was it buy this for
the kids Christmas for the C which is
the one that for some reason had the
heavy from TF2 in it what that was Team
Fortress was Mod Nation oh maybe not no
I think they added into the PC version
of something yeah really along with
football manager guy yeah football
manager guy football football manager
guy there's a football kidding me the
dude on the box yeah yeah he's got he's
got a helmet on covering up the top of
his head no isn't he just a dude in a
suit yeah he hasn't got a face either
it's just like generic yeah football
manager you did actually happen that is
wonderful exactly right that is amazing
that was a decent game this is a good
game as well but that was also a decent
game you actually got will the next one
have baby football manager guy oh my God
all right I'm back on board between that
and the Anthony keas DLC I think I'm
they're really reaching the jaded game
Journal
crowd that's a big Market a Big B market
those guys love to spend their money
take me to the place I love Mario Kart
take me all the
way I'm a bullet I am finding playing as
Kevin very
difficult are you the one in the
comically oversized vehicle I could be
it's very te are you just unsure about
yourself in your lad in Life or is that
are you trying to be COI COI okay he's
thinking about his wild star review
instead of thinking about the road he's
really getting kin he's really getting
into it as Kevin I see
that Kevin's really good review in this
super
yeah Fair player to him super good at it
I would probably pass out and
exhaust that happens every day
anyway called after
lunch we did have a big lunch did you
what have I had a squid had chicken half
a chicken you had you had half a chicken
did you go to that place that I just saw
someone walking away with half a chicken
in Pocket that was me yeah
boom thanks thanks Mar car one turn for
the end of the
race God someone finished off me that
was really
difficult you were WoW race is heating
up for I'm tying with Kevin not last I'm
also sorry to anyone giving this that
actually wanted to watch some like Pro
Mario Kart play oh yeah no I didn't
invite any pro Mario Kart players on
this stream we have them Tom m is very
good Max Holbert also very good at Mario
Kart but they just sit there fuming
wouldn't they they just sit there quiet
fuming yeah no those guys
would yeah a big ass Bowser that's a big
Bowser big ass Bowser is the latest you
guys better kick it up a not here we got
to make him big ass
Bowser Bowser the kids love regular
Bowser give them what they want Big Baby
Bowser is Babs he's got a huge
ass I want to see my kids you shut up
and make them bigger you see your kids
when you're dead when I was shooting him
I didn't get to see my kids said shikar
Fame video game developer designer
shikar Yoto he's a cranky CR got a h me
and dairo go way back oh did I say dairo
I meant Pete
hind this summer Pete hies and Sh in the
it's the Buddy comedy you all
wanted Hey where's Fallout 4 I don't
know where's the new
Zelda
I'll announce Skyrim 2 if you announce
4 oh those
guys shy shy and
Petey and when they're together people
refer to them
as I can't think of it next week on shy
and P
okay mamoto I'm going to go to the shop
here's the source code here's the source
code for Fallout 4 I'm going to put it
on this table right next to this CD that
has the source code for The Elder
Scrolls online now whatever you do don't
get don't get them
confused
okay Todd Howard is going to come over
and he wants that ESO the fall we're
going to release ESO make sure you post
this one the the blue
now this won't be but I'm color
blind
Meo oh
shsy shsy you really shs that one up
didn't
you how you
doing okay mamoto now in this binder is
our lawsuit against John
Kack and in this binder
is the evidence proving we have no case
now now one things need to be posted to
Chris
Waters the other needs to be shredded so
that no one went off find C to 2 days
later at the games spot office Chris is
unopening oh that package finally came
in from
shy finally wait a second wait a second
they no guys get kach on the
blower
come back come come to the phone he's in
a virtual reality space
suit he's launching a rocket or at least
he thinks he
is he's in space hanging out with quite
a cast of characters he's in space
hanging out with Richard garot are these
all animated it's the spin-off show it's
the spin-off show garad and car G and in
space that's where two people have the
longest most boring conversation in the
world that Shader or something
you tell me about your rockets and I'll
tell you about my house that's a
castle you tell me about your Rockets
John con can I tell all the games that
I've made me Richard gar you tell games
such as tabularasa tabularasa you tell
me about rage and I'll tell you about
tabularasa oh good
times I'm very sorry to anyone wanted
serious Mario Kart I'm quite I feel like
this is serious Mario Kart Mario Kart
and talking weirdness I'm quite J I'm
not to Dan in like8
months sorry Dan it's pretty much the
first time I've met Dan and he space
station not Fu up rainbow PS they [__]
up Rainbow Road what is bad about this
rainbow road it's a rainbow SP but it
used to be just want to say I'm going to
use the motion controls for this race oh
this is going to be terrible this is
what happens when you have you try
and
extension oh God what's the
rainbow yeah what's the can people see
yeah the kids want to know why Rainbow
Road exists wait wait what it's a bunch
of LEDs in space it's just a construct
it's not actually a real place sh you
shut up you get out of my office I'll
never work in this business again we got
the rich fiction when we make the MMO
people are going to want to know where
the road is yeah rainbow mum
mode what why don't we have some dry
bones up there s some dry bones up there
some dry bones some some of those cows
mum they're they don't need to breis
there it works it's totally plausible
within the fiction they're mumo we can't
call them cows we have to pay the dairy
Lobby we can't take a cup we can't bre
the dairy Lobby we can just do the
YouTube thing call them mumo great I got
I got the least useful power of on
Rainbow Road super mushroom super
mushroom it's like it's like a super
rocket off the edge I like being the
Bullet cuz I don't have to steal with
this stupid controlling how is the super
controlling uh it's stupid right it's
called a road it's called a space
station shoot rainbow can I just I'm
going to have a look at look at earth
right this is the first time I thought
that Mario is actually you know what
this reminds me of is an Unreal
Tournament level yes we facing mod no
this is this is Morpheus yeah this is
where could be say look at this look at
look at the world on down there that
looks real I don't like that are you say
look at that look at that what is that
is this is that like can you make out a
country yeah we're currently flying over
some kind of peninsula oh my God down
again is that Japan that's totally Japan
that's
Japan this is in space kids so where on
Earth if you go out in your backyard at
2: a.m. tonight with a telescope it's in
Amsterdam and you see a rainbow in the
sky yeah there's actually a there's
actually a load of babies the shooting
star is a baby falling off and burning
up upon
re-entry it's hilarious I got a star
it's the worst it's the wacky thing that
the whole family could
enjoy upload videos to YouTube
so this thing is like you're either
turning all the way left or all the way
right oh and going off the it's digital
oh look I just saw John carach fly past
in a
rocket this uh it's when they get ran
making like Mario act zero and it's
Mario Kart Origins Mario Kart that'll be
great we're telling the story of how the
babies there should be baby Yoshi and it
should just be an egg that's pretty good
yeah come on Nintendo you can take that
one it's just rolling down the track or
maybe his legs are sticking out like in
uh acne Farm that' be real or in what
was that what was that Garfield cartoon
Chuck rock chuck chuck Rock [__]
Chuck Rock remember how zoomed in that
game was that game was so zoomed Inu
Rock I love Chuck Rock Chuck Rock to
what did you love to do Chuck Rock um I
love to Chuck Rock the ROP yeah pretty
much the rock Chuck that was a good bit
hey Chris is this annoying is this
annoying Chris Chris you are really just
rubbing rubbing his racing over here we
got this character we don't have a name
for him what's he do oh he Chuck's rocks
Chuck rocks we're going to call him
Craig it's like Craig but it it's more
more sophisticated get out of my office
we're going to call him The Rock Dwayne
Johnson we're going to call him Dwayne
Johnson Dwayne Dwayne Johnson I'd like
to say that I got ahead of not doing too
terribly hey I got head of Dan and I
spent a good like minute throwing myself
off the track so I could see if it was
fling right I spent a good 2 minutes
doing that wait wait wait
wait oh gosh it's okay wait
no what are the other wait right up
thought that wasn't on camera that
awkward high five we just screwed up
real bad yes CL you just clipped hey he
made it w Bravo inre Soldier fantastic
there is another Rainbow Road this is
the futuristic one there's actually a
different level it's a retro rainbow
road but I think we're leave after for
another time as Danny capacious yawn
signals that we're probably done
here thank you very much for having me
on Martin you're a pleasure to have on
as always sorry we ruined your show no I
think you guys did okay I think you're
like really leaned into the niche
audience of uh people that appreciate
John carac fiction a lot ofan fiction
about
prominent video game industry individual
I'm sorry it's just my entire life next
week on multiple players tabula rasa
Danny what's happening tomorrow man
what's on the lobby the Lobby's on yeah
uh E3 is on next week no way so we're
going to sit down and talk about
everyone's here talk about E3 this guy
and this guy and this guy and maybe this
guy you have like 23 hours to prepare y
all my questions about tabularasa and
rage can that be the first question tell
me about rage two so yeah can't wait to
see that new it engine it's gonna be
glorious and uh that's at 2m tomorrow
thanks for watching multiple players 2 p
P.M every Monday Pacific Time Of course
uh except for next Monday we're not
going to have it's going to be E3 and
the Monday after probably not going to
have it because of e3 shell shock and
also all of our equipment being down in
Los Angeles and on a truck back so look
to the return of multiple players in two
weeks thank you guys for watching so
much we'll see you later bye
bye